yeah the book was better I'm just
talking I haven't read moby-dick
seen this movie though and I could
venture a guess in the heart of the sea
so in the heart of the sea is the
supposed true story that inspired the
fictional work of Moby Dick
at first it starts out as an
interviewing this guy's interviewing the
youngest crew member of Chris
Hemsworth's crew and then we see his
story and then we meet up with Chris
Hemsworth who plays first mate of a
whaling ship in the 1800's whaling was
really huge everyone wanted that blubber
in oil so Chris Hemsworth and his crew
they'll go out there to find some whales
a surgeon and the water they're out
there doing whaling guy things haven't
found any whales yet but we're looking
for him and stuff and then they
eventually finally find some whales and
they do some whaling things and this is
one big-ass whale is super pissed and he
beats the living out of the ship
then they're all stranded in their
lifeboats and they got nowhere to go
they're 2,000 miles away from anything
and everything so now they're in the
lifeboats doing the lifeboat thing down
there in the water there's no one around
we're all waiting waiting to be rescued
waiting to be rescued
still waiting another hours of movie
goes by and oh look at that that's two
hours the movies done what does snooze
so serious is movie was a board it's
really depressing coming from Ron Howard
about halfway through the movie I was
like he had to have been a producer now
he directed this movie and you can
recognize the movies directed by a
director who has talent a lot of these
shots they worked really well
they were the money it's just movie I
guess he's not Moby Dick because the the
books not coined yet he doesn't have a
name he's just a big white whale but
there's some scenes Werth's on his nose
is just going and then BAM this ship
just gets wrecked I was like all right
that's low I'm perking up oh that was
some exciting that whale is pissed
oh that's four minutes of the movie all
right back to doing what we're doing
doing a lifeboat thing gotten there in
the water still waiting I'll give it up
for Chris Hemsworth in this movie and
generally speaking everyone in the movie
did a fine job Chris Hemsworth you know
being the star we're gonna talk about
him most
didn't did a good job in this role he
has to sequentially get skinnier and
more and more fatigued as the movies
going on because that's really what the
movies about it is a shipwreck movie
don't let the trailer tell you any
different what on an island no out on
boats in the middle of nowhere
it's really funny I was singing about
this on the ride home this movie is the
entire premise of The Life of Pi Life of
Pi just did it better I know there's
going to be some pseudo-intellectual
in the comment section it's
gonna be like you didn't understand the
movie it's showing that if you take away
everything that we rely on we're just
all animals on the inside we're no
better than the beasts we try to destroy
holy old and overused doesn't even
begin to cover that and I like that
premise yeah give it to me a hundred
times over just don't bore me while
you're doing it I've just seen that
premise done a hundred times better the
characters in this movie they're not
that interesting if you're going to have
a movie where people are starving to
death make me care about the fact that
they are starving to death no you don't
care about them so you really don't care
about the emotional crux of the movie
that the movies trying to go for so you
really don't care about the movie in the
end Chris Hemsworth did a fine job in
the movie the movie had an exciting
scene or two the movie was boring on the
build-up but I thought all right the
next half of the movie will be more
entertaining the next half of the movie
is not funny thing Brendan Gleeson in
the beginning of the movie is the guy
being interviewed and he even says he's
like I'm gonna tell you the story but
you're going to be disappointed and it's
totally true it's just the reality of
the story is not as interesting as the
fiction of the story and I suppose this
is a good lesson of why people
fictionalized things because it's just
more interesting that way bummer is this
is my least favorite Ron Howard movie
ever that I can think of anyway it
breaks my heart to say I'm not going to
remember this movie in t-minus one day
ya already forgot I so in the heart of
the sea have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
Ron Howard movie of all time we'll do
that we'll talk the dude up a little bit
tearing the out of him here so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you